They say that humans are a dog's best friend and I think that's true.
Hey Gus, tonight is very important to me, okay?
I haven't had a date in a very long time.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
He overthinks it.
You chase each other around and then you lick each other's faces.
And it's on. Simple.
Now here's the part that kills me.
They're hungry, there's food in front of them and they just blab for hours.
What do you like to do on the weekends?
Uh-oh!
Don't say it.
Taxes.
Oh, you said it.
Really? That's...
I just do taxes like, all the time.
All right.
Oh my god, Gus!
I love him.
Oh! Awesome.
Yes, it's true.
Part of being a best friend does mean you have to run interference when it's needed.
He is so cool.
Yeah, yeah, he's a good dog.
Well, in any case, if anyone out there wants a dinner date with me, I keep it simple.
Set the table, fill your plates with healthy, delicious food and then we eat.
We can save the talking for when we're full.